[Music]
[Applause]
Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one color
analyst and host of Ross Tucker football
podcast
Ross good to have you back buddy if
you're the Green Bay Packers what do you
do with your quarterbacking situation
well I like the way you phrased that Dan
because it is the Green Bay Packers
decision to make I thought it was
interesting
seeing some comments from last night
about Aaron Rodgers where he said you
know as long as they're not
mathematically eliminated he'd like to
still be out there which to me Dan
Intimates that if they are
mathematically eliminated he doesn't
want to be out there which I think is a
bad message to send as a starting
quarterback and leader of the team I
mean what if the other guys all said
that you think David bakhtiari with his
arthritic knee wants to be out there the
rest of year you think Mercedes Lewis in
year 17 wants to play four or five games
playing out the string no and I
understand what Aaron's coming from but
to me that's the Packers organization
their decision to make I think I need to
know more about his medical status for
this week but with the thumb and the
ribs and the pain he was in having to
leave the game if he's not a hundred
percent I'd probably put Jordan love out
out there and based on how that game
goes I don't know if you put Rogers back
in I mean if they win that probably
means Jordan love played pretty well so
maybe keep him in there if they lose
then they're definitely mathematically
eliminated so then why would you put
Rogers back in then you want to get love
some experience for the rest of the year
so either way I don't know if we'll see
Aaron Rodgers again this year or maybe
ever in a Packer's uniform why do you
say ever
well the way they structured that
contract it certainly feels like it's a
year-to-year thing
and I don't know that they're gonna want
him back next year that he's going to
want to be back next year I think
there's a
pretty decent percentage chance that
maybe he would walk away or retire he
certainly seems like a guy that has a
bunch of other interests other things he
could be into they might decide it's
time for year four of Jordan love to
finally give him the keys to the car I
thought he looked really good made some
good throws last night or maybe they
just they know it's kind of more of a
rebuild situation so I think there's a
pretty good chance and maybe Aaron just
wants to go somewhere else maybe he's
frustrated with what they did or didn't
do this off-season and wants to give it
one more shot another uniform kind of
like Tom Brady did down in Tampa
yeah I just wonder if they already know
what they have with Jordan love if
you're with somebody in practice every
day and you've been with him for three
years I'm gonna guess you have an idea
if Jordan love is your future do you say
that's a fair assessment for the Packers
um
I would say I know where you're coming
from but if you remember I think it
might have been after Roger's second
year the Packers took Brian Braum out of
Louisville in the second round
I don't think they knew what they had
Roger okay after two years I mean they
took Brahm out of Louisville I don't
think they really knew that Rogers would
be what he ended up being and I do think
based on what Collinsworth was saying
last night and what other people have
said they feel like this off season when
Rogers wasn't there that Jordan love
took that step from year two to year
three when he had all those practices to
be the guy foreign
the jet situation Zach Wilson doesn't
even dress Mike White comes in and when
Mike White plays they usually have over
400 yards of offense there at what point
do you say Mike White is our starting
quarterback until further notice
I think it needs to be at least two
three four more weeks because I don't
remember exactly Dan but didn't he have
an awesome game or two last year and
then we all kind of got excited about it
and I want I feel like they played
Indianapolis or something and he was
terrible three Anderson so what makes
you you a good quarterback Dan and you
know this it's the consistency that's
what professional football is about it's
week in week out he went against a
really bad Bears defense I think we can
pump the brakes until I would want at
least a four game sample size before I
would announce anything publicly right
you know you can go one week at a time
right now as long as Mike White's
playing well it almost is like a Taylor
heinecke situation with the commanders
of Washington after you've got four
games and it's clear that the guy is
playing well in the team and rallies
around him then you can say White's the
guy for the rest of the year but you
have him playing at the Vikings and at
the bills do the Jets win when Zach
Wilson in that situation or would they
rather have Mike White
literally everybody in the organization
knows they have a better chance to win
with Mike White
which is a problem why why is Mike White
better
is it Zach Wilson's not good or Mike
White is better than what we think
uh combination of both I think Mike
White has a chance to be average maybe
above average maybe a solid starting
quarterback and Zach Wilson then he was
playing like one of the worst
quarterbacks in the league I mean he was
I think he was 33rd in a league that has
32 starting quarterbacks that's hard to
do
yeah I that and that's the problem right
the Jets realized at some point if we
just get top 25 quarterback play you
know we can win these games we just
can't have the worst guy out there we
can't have a guy that's not I mean they
had two yards two in the second half
against the Patriots and Zach Wilson's
last start
you did the Cowboys and the Giants game
do the Cowboys have enough weapons that
they don't need Odell Beckham
that is a great question because someone
was asking me recently to compare the
Cowboys and the Eagles
and I do think there's some similarities
I think the NFC has four really good
teams with the Vikings the Niners and
then the Cowboys and the Eagles but the
difference to me between the Eagles and
the Cowboys is probably two-fold number
one Jalen hurts much more willing to run
and more effective than Dak Prescott but
number two you look at the Cowboys and
it's you know they got the running backs
but then it's CD lamb don't Schultz
tight ends are pretty good Eagles AJ
Brown Devonte Smith Quest Watkins is a
good number three when they get Dallas
got her back he's a top three Titan I
think if the Cowboys are serious about
trying to get to the Super Bowl this
year they probably do need to add
another weapon like Odell Beckham Jr it
feels like they're going to come up one
guy short when they get to the playoffs
against you know a team like San
Francisco or Philadelphia
I hope Jalen hurts is a legitimate MVP
candidate I hope Tua is as well because
I I it's almost like we're still waiting
we're not quite sure if their franchise
quarterback Jalen hurts has answered
every question and then some and two
after he got hurt has been unbelievable
I think it's Patrick mahomes's MVP to
lose here but where do you stand in the
rankings there of MVP candidates so far
those guys are both top five probably
top three right now they have both
played at an incredible level and for
whatever reason Dan this is a human
being thing certainly a social media
thing it is hard
for us to move past our preconceived
notions or our initial Impressions on
someone so Mahomes was amazing right
away and he is amazing so that's all we
think of him as we saw two a playback we
saw Jalen hurts not play that well so
it's really hard for us to believe that
guys can improve as much as they have
and so when you watch Tua or you watch
hurts you watch them and you're like
yeah he's playing well yeah he's good
but you still don't think he's my home
and probably neither one of those guys
are as gifted as Mahomes but in the
context of their offenses what they're
being asked to do both those guys are
playing at a really really high level
and I love Dan just as an aside for the
first time now your MVP vote is going to
be five guys you know you rank them one
two three four five so we actually get
to see okay how many votes did this guy
get how many votes because otherwise it
used to just be you could only vote for
one guy I think right now Jalen hurts
and tuatanga violoa should probably be
two and three
we're talking to Ross Tucker CBS
Westwood one color analyst host of the
Russ Tucker football podcast also even
money betting podcast as well the
situation with Russell Wilson and a
backup defensive lineman Mike Purcell
let us understand that
Russ said it's not a big deal he got
yelled at by a defensive lineman or
however we want to phrase it but this is
different it feels like this is Aaron
Donald's not yelling at Matthew Stafford
uh what do you make of this
it's not good no matter how you slice it
I guess I would be very curious to hear
what he actually said and what the tone
was right because there's a difference
then between going over and saying hey
let's go we need you guys to get
something done come on man you can do
this like almost encouraging versus like
you better pick your you know what up
this is BS I I would really like to know
the exact phrasing and tone with which
Mike Purcell said it could have been an
encouraging Vibe or it could have been
very demeaning what do you think it was
um
probably encouraging on some level
probably fiery encouraging because I
don't think Mike Purcell is that stupid
to be saying really bad things to the
guy that just signed the gigantic
guaranteed contract right like if I was
playing Dan as your backup online or
maybe I'm starting I'm not yelling at
the guy that just got the huge contract
and could probably say hey get rid of
this guy in a heartbeat I'm not saying
anything bad to that guy it's like
that's what people always say to me like
you know if you were in the locker room
Ross what would you say to this star
player who did like I'd say nothing to
him no he wouldn't say anything to him
nothing so you would be happy that I'm
in the locker room you never yelled at
Tom Brady when you were with the
Patriots
definitely not I don't think I ever
yelled at any quarterback no I was never
and honestly like it is funny because
guys know where their bread is buttered
you know I know offensive lineman that
specifically wanted to Buddy up with the
starting in quarterbacks because they
knew those guys have a lot of influence
with the coaches so no I don't think I
mean now high school and college I
definitely did but you get to the NFL
and you realize uh those guys have a lot
more clout than I do
great to talk to you as always thank you
bud always shout out chat Rowe Ross
Tucker CBS Westwood one color analyst
host of the Ross Tucker football podcast